I spent 20 million yen repairing the roof of
my house I don't have that kind of money I don't have that kind of money I can compare the memories of the Mizusaki family
30,000 yen won't be enough paril right?
It was a good deal, it was in
Tokyo,
but maybe the roof and walls should be prioritized
.  That's right,
it
's a villa just for us Let's make it comfortable with the sofa, the TV, and the Honda all over.
The
roof is open,
and the picture is taken from here.
It's light and strong enough,
and it has a built-in attitude control system, so anyone can
stop
it at will
.  Music]
Yes, you can keep your sexuality
If there is an empty space in this, the building will collapse.
I'll
explain the settings even in this state